y con eso primero invitado el día vamos
a hablar precisamente del más reciente
informe de la organización
donde plasma la preocupación de los
regímenes autoritarios en todo el mundo
para el análisis saludamos en este
momento a Juan papier el subdirector en
funciones para las Américas de Human
right watch Juana Gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 y Comencemos hablando entonces en
nuestra región de América Latina y el
Caribe le preguntó cuáles son los casos
más preocupantes en esta región en
términos de retroceso de los Derechos
Humanos
Muchas gracias a ti por la invitación
Mira América Latina está en un momento
muy difícil para la democracia y los
Derechos Humanos tenemos por supuesto
tres dictaduras que nos preocupan
enormemente Cuba Venezuela y Nicaragua
Pero también tenemos gobiernos que han
sido elegidos democráticamente y que se
dedican a destruir las instituciones
democráticas es el que el caso por
ejemplo de el gobierno de nayib bukele
en El Salvador de Alejandro chamatei en
Guatemala de Andrés Manuel López Obrador
en México y lo que lo que ocurre y el
punto central que nosotros queremos
hacer con este informe este año es que
es necesario que los gobiernos
democráticos empiecen a tomar medidas
efectivas para responder a las grandes
preocupaciones que tiene la ciudadanía
la inseguridad la corrupción
la pobreza si si se responde a estos
problemas Entonces no va a haber motivos
para que la ciudadanía elija gobernantes
populistas que propone respuestas que
pueden sonar sencillas pero que resultan
generalmente en violaciones derechos
humanos una pregunta A lo mejor
complicada de resolver no Y cómo hacer
para fortalecer todo el sistema
institucional sobre todo en la región de
América Latina y el Caribe para que este
tipo de cosas no pase ni evidentemente
la ciudadanía y la población esté
blindada con unas instituciones fuertes
y y alejadas a la corrupción que tanto
aqueja a nuestra región
necesitamos en la región recuperar los
consensos que existían sobre
la importancia es un valor central de la
Democracia que está cada vez en más
atacado por distintos gobiernos de la
región Pero además
necesitamos como te decía que los que
los gobiernos empiecen a dar resultados
cuando cuando no se dan resultados para
enfrentar los problemas que afectan a la
ciudadanía en el día a día entonces eso
genera una situación de desesperación
que hace que los ciudadanos a veces
adopten decisiones que en el largo plazo
terminan siendo contraproducentes como
es elegir estos líderes mesiánicos que
vienen a destruir la democracia es
fundamental que los gobiernos
democráticos prioricen los temas claves
inseguridad pobreza corrupción y
empiecen a dar resultados en estos temas
para evitar estos manotazos de ahogado
que toma la ciudadanía eligiendo estos
líderes populistas autoritarios claro y
precisamente esto también lo podemos
catalogar como una erosión a la
confianza digamos de la población a los
sistemas democráticos eligiendo a estas
personas que son un tipo de Mesías que
la depositan su confianza no la
ciudadanía para que arreglen todos los
problemas de la región pero ya vemos que
así como es el caso del Salvador que
volvió también a ampliar este estado de
excepción contra las pandillas para
luchar contra las pandillas pero que se
han denunciado una cantidad sin fin de
de violaciones a los derechos humanos o
también no
en El Salvador lo que estamos viendo Es
por supuesto el hartazgo de la
ciudadanía por las por los gravísimos
abusos brutales que cometen las
pandillas que llevó la elección de este
líder populista autoritario como es
nayib bukele y la política que adoptó el
gobierno de bukele ha sido suspender los
derechos fundamentales de los
salvadoreños ya desde el mes de marzo
están suspendidos varios derechos
fundamentales y se han cometido como
parte de lo que el gobierno llama una
guerra contra las pandillas violaciones
generalizadas de Derechos Humanos
estamos hablando de detenciones
arbitrarias de personas que lo tienen
nada que ver con las pandillas niños
personas con discapacidad conductores de
Uber cualquier persona puede ser
detenido en El Salvador y algunos se han
enfrentado a desapariciones forzadas
casos de torturas y un proceso judicial
verdaderamente caffiano que hace
imposible que estas personas puedan
defenderse y probar su inocencia claro
eh Juan también es el lado digamos o por
una derecha no pero también tenemos el
contraste de otros gobiernos en nuestras
regiones elegidos recientemente Como por
ejemplo el de Colombia el de Gustavo
Petro fue de tantos años también de la
gobernanza de la derecha en Colombia
casi inexistente la izquierda vino Un
gobierno de izquierda a este país
también con la reelección digamos
después de años apartado de de la
presidencia de Lula Silva en Brasil
digamos que en estos dos países en
Colombia y Brasil se puede ver que los
ciudadanos y intentan reconciliarse de
alguna manera con la democracia
vamos a verlo Ojalá sea así Creo que los
ejemplos de Colombia Brasil son
distintos en varios sentidos lo lo la
buena noticia en Colombia es que la
democracia ha sido capaz de procesar
esta transición democrática de la
derecha a un gobernante que por primera
vez es izquierda y eso ha ocurrido sin
mayores obstáculos de forma ordenada
pacífica tranquila Lamentablemente en
Brasil estamos viendo enormes
dificultades como vimos este domingo con
este ataque de esta de estos ciudadanos
que quieren impedir que los brasileños
puedan ejercer su derecho a votar y a
elegir a su presidente el presidente que
haya sido electo el presidente de Lula
da Silva luego los los desafíos de estos
gobernantes en estos países son muy
distintos el presidente Petro tiene que
enfrentar el gran problema de Derechos
Humanos que hay en Colombia que es la
inseguridad la violencia por parte de
grupos armados y criminales y en Brasil
lo que hay que hacer es progresivamente
recuperar la vigencia de derechos
fundamentales que han sido dañados
severamente por el presidente bolsona
los derechos de la mujer los derechos de
la población lgbt y sobre todo enfrentar
el problema masivo del Amazonas donde se
nos juega digamos la gran contribución
que puede hacer América Latina para
frenar el fenómeno existencial del
cambio climático por supuesto Juan
También tenemos que hablar de la región
central el caso más preocupante Además
del Salvador por supuesto está en
Nicaragua donde el gobierno se ha
dedicado a reprimir a cualquier tipo de
de disidencia unas elecciones
presidenciales prácticamente sin ningún
tipo de oposición también los defensores
de Derechos Humanos reprimidos por el
régimen de Ortega el el régimen de
Ortega también pues ha desmantelado casi
todas las instituciones del país que
pasa específicamente con el caso
nicaragüense
Mira Nicaragua es una dictadura pura y
dura probablemente sea uno de los peores
situaciones de Derechos Humanos que hoy
tenemos en nuestro continente estamos
hablando de un país con 200 precios
políticos estamos hablando de un régimen
que ha clausurado a tres mil ongs casi
el 50% de la ongs que existen en
Nicaragua según los registros oficiales
han sido clausuradas por el gobierno es
decir un país donde no hay ninguna
posibilidad de criticar libremente al
gobierno donde cualquiera que lo hace
puede ser detenido puede ser
sometido a todo tipo de abusos estamos
siendo un país que que poco a poco se va
convirtiendo virtualmente en la Corea
del norte de nuestro continente eso
tiene que ser de enorme preocupación
para los gobiernos democráticos de la
región que deberían trabajar de forma
conjunta para forzar una transición
democrática en Nicaragua Juan Nicaragua
ha superado a Venezuela en términos de
violación a los Derechos Humanos
Mira es muy difícil nosotros no hacemos
rankings de de comparación de los
distintos países y es difícil comparar
en Venezuela también hay precios
políticos por supuesto y hay una
represión sistemática del disenso al
igual que Nicaragua y además hay otros
desafíos como la crisis humanitaria y la
crisis migratoria siete millones de
venezolanos que han salido del país
muchos de ellos a Colombia muchos de
ellos están cruzando el tapón del Darién
es decir la desesperación de estas
personas por salir de Venezuela es
enorme y la situación de Derechos
Humanos ahí también Debería ser una
prioridad para los gobernantes
democráticos de la región Juana dos
temas que quiero tratar contigo antes de
despedir nuestra conversación México una
impunidad eterna gobierno tras gobierno
qué pasa con estos casos que nunca se
han resuelto sobre todo también de
asesinatos a periodistas
México tiene un problema de violencia
muy preocupante
Qué resultado en parte de políticas
fracasadas en materia de seguridad de
una guerra contra las drogas de una
estrategia de militarización el
presidente Andrés Manuel López Obrador
cuando era candidato siempre se oponía a
la estrategia de militarización y se
presentaba como un presidente en futuro
presidente humanista lo que ha ocurrido
durante su mandato Es que él ha
profundizado como como nadie en la
historia de México la militarización del
país y esto ha llevado por un lado a la
desprotección de la ciudadanía porque se
trata de una estrategia de seguridad
fallida que no da resultados en la que
han aumentado por el contrario los
índices de homicidios Pero además ha
deteriorado la democracia mexicana
porque el poder que tiene cada vez más
los militares por ejemplo desempeñando
tareas de civiles hace que se puedan
se genere opacidad sobre las tareas que
desempeñan y haya lugares para la
corrupción y para la y para la y para la
falta de transparencia
todo esto en un contexto de un sistema
de Justicia que no funciona que no ha
resultados para investigar los delitos y
para lograr justicia para las víctimas
de estos gravísimos abusos Juan
terminemos en Asia vamos a tratar si
podemos resumir cuatro países en una
sola respuesta la situación de sobre
todo las mujeres en Afganistán tras la
vuelta de los talibanes al poder también
la situación de los gugures en China
reprimidos por el gobierno de chilling
Pink la junta militar de birmania que
sigue también persiguiendo a los
rojillas que quedan ahí se están
expandiendo hasta bangla ella hay
preocupación ahí y por supuesto las
protestas en Irán
mira Son todas situaciones de la mayor
preocupación para Swatch Irán como tú
dices con incluso las ejecuciones
de personas la pena de muerte que se
está empleando La dictadura en en mi
amar o burma que ha cometido violaciones
sistemáticas derechos humanos crímenes
de lesa humanidad y en Afganistán con
los abusos
sistemáticos generalizados que impiden
que las mujeres que las niñas puedan
tener una vida y desarrollarse como como
personas y ejercer por ejemplo su
derecho esencial básico a la educación
creo que el el la atención internacional
sobre estos sobre estos países y otros
por ejemplo eritrea Debería ser mucho
mayor y deberías de haber mucha más
acción por parte de la comunidad
internacional y la comunidad
internacional puede hacer más y la mayor
evidencia de eso es la guerra en Ucrania
la guerra en Ucrania donde se cometen
crímenes de guerra horrorosos ha
generado respuestas ejemplares de la
comunidad internacional con
investigaciones en el consejo de
Derechos Humanos investigaciones a la
Corte Penal Internacional solidaridad
para que nos puedan llegar a Europa y
recuperar sus vidas Ese es el tipo de
respuesta que debería ser un modelo para
responder a estas crisis de Derechos
Humanos que tú mencionas en otros países
del mundo